i just want to wrap up these speeches i  don't think we've hit on it hard enough  that the fact that the vice president  conveyed that january 6 2020  won  was like december 7th 1941 and september  11  2001. even for some people who are going  to condemn the attacks and the riot and  they're going to find that i think  pretty hyperbolic and for 9 11  family survivors maybe insulting we may  see that backlash and and the other  thing is the the president going  specifically  numerous times to defeated uh beaten  talking about failed lost it was almost  that he was trying to stir former  president trump into saying something  today and we'll see if that happens